when he was the mayor of San Francisco
in 2008 Gavin Newsome announced a
10-year plan to end chronic homelessness
in the city that was a big challenge
Nome said and that's why it would take a
decade longer than it took us to land
the first men on the moon after Kennedy
promised to do so but after 10 years
Newsome insisted the residents of San
Francisco would finally be able to enjoy
their City without hordes of junkies and
prostitutes and mentally ill vagrants
wandering around downtown and defecating
on everything watch we believe
fundamentally that food solves hunger
that shelters solve sleep and that
housing solves homelessness and if we're
going to solve the problem uh of those
that are out on the streets that we
Define as homeless we better solve the
housing problem if we're going to have
an impact and that's why we established
this framework what we call a 10-year
plan to end Chona colus in San
Francisco now in case you missed the
logic there here it is one more time
time food solves hunger shelter solves
sleep and housing solves homelessness
these are deep insights I'm surprised he
didn't also point out that dry land
solves drowning and breathing solves
Suffocation and not having cancer solves
cancer now at the time people living in
San Francisco thought that this platform
made sense they didn't think it was a
bunch of meaningless platitudes they
also didn't ask what it means for
shelter to solve sleep on second thought
I mean what does that mean does you
think that people with houses don't
sleep what does that mean exactly anyway
they just went with it didn't ask any
questions and you know give the guy 10
years they said let him cook as the kids
say pretty soon everybody will have
homes and uh nobody will be sleeping or
something but predictably enough Gavin
nome's 10-year plan turned out a lot
like Greta thunberg's promise that the
world would end by 2023 it never
materialized and everybody involved knew
that it would never materialize not that
Nome stuck around for 10 years to find
out he became lieutenant governor of
California just 3 years after announcing
his big 10-year plan and then he moved
up to governor in 2019 and through it
all in the hands of Nome and his
deputies the problem of homelessness in
s in San Francisco and in California at
large only became progressively worse
and year after year the residents of San
Francisco have heard excuse after excuse
for this failure the excuses kept
changing but one thing remained constant
which is that it was never the fault of
politicians right it's always somebody
else's fault now lately politicians in
the city have settled on a new excuse
they're BL cling federal courts for the
homelessness crisis here's San Francisco
mayor London breed for example just a
couple of months ago offering uh this
excuse
watch let's not let a one judge impact
our ability to do what all San
franciscans won they want clean streets
they want homeless people to be helped
and that is exactly what we are trying
to
do today the fight over homeless sweeps
intensifies as an impassion mayor London
breed pleads for the 9th Circuit Court
of Appeals to lift an injunction that
temporarily blocks the city from
clearing homeless
encampments so London breed blames a
federal judge for the homelessness
problem in the city and people
apparently agree with her you know there
was a crowd there they were cheering
along more than a decade after Newsome
promise to end homelessness people are
cheering for a mayor who's coming up
with excuses for why her party
completely failed to do that the problem
breed says is a judge issued some
injunction within the past year and
that's why the plan to end homelessness
didn't work over the past 15 years and
by the way the government is the only
place where it works this way right it's
the only place where you can go to your
boss with an excuse for why you utterly
failed to do what you were paid to do
and then get a standing ovation doesn't
really work like that uh in most places
in the private sector now to be fair to
London breed though a judge did recently
issue an injunction against the city
preventing them from removing homeless
encampments unless they had shelter beds
uh to house everyone and yes that was a
dumb ruling the ninth circuit later
clarified that the city C can remove
homeless encampments as long as the
homeless people decline an offer of
housing so that's something that's
that's where that stands but all this
legal wrangling is just the latest
excuse that people in San Francisco have
heard when they ask why homelessness is
still completely out of control every
year there's a new explanation last year
for example Newsome blame the economy
and Co for why his plan to end
homelessness wasn't actually ending
homelessness he said quote we're dealing
with unprecedented economic contraction
the worst In Our Lifetime induced by a
pandemic now a few years before that in
2012 Nome attacked people who pointed
out that homelessness was getting worse
saying that they were just being cynical
and uh and playing politics then
speaking to the Los Angeles Times Nome
defended his 10-year plan saying that
Michelangelo taught him that it's better
to set a high bar and fail than to set a
low bar and meet it now of course
Michelangelo was talking about artistic
Pursuits we can assume where that rule
May apply but with politicians you'd
much rather they set out to do simple
things and then actually do those simple
things rather than claim they're going
to do a big thing and instead do nothing
at all which is usually what
happens what do we take from this if you
live in California the message is pretty
clear homelessness is just something you
have to deal with no 10-year plan no
matter how well-funded it is can
possibly solve it it's a fact of life
the best you could hope for is helping a
few thousand homeless people as hordes
more homeless people arrive that's the
reality of life in a big city and if you
disagree Gavin Newsome will tell you
that you're part of the problem and
that's all why it's been so interesting
to watch what's been happening in San
Francisco over the past few days now
this week San Francisco has hosting the
Apec Summit which will attract Business
Leaders tourists and nearly two dozen
heads of state incl including Joe Biden
and Chinese president gin ping ping and
response and they're all coming to the
city to San Francisco in response for
the first time in a generation virtually
overnight the city of San Francisco has
cleaned the streets homeless encampments
have been forcibly moved out of sight
the place looks presentable again even
livable if you can believe it and
residents of the city are completely
stunned they had no idea that anything
like this was possible watch the Summit
is expected to bring in $53 million
filling hotel rooms bringing big
business and the city did Tidy Up For
Dream Force but this cleanup is much
more
extensive while San Francisco is in the
spotlight for the asia-pacific economic
conference city leaders are making sure
the city shines tourism is our business
here in San Francisco and we need to
focus on making sure that the tourist
dollars still come back calr repaving
major roadways like the Harrison Street
offramp from the I80 Bart doubling down
by deep cleaning their stations
overnight more often the city had gotten
a little bit dingy over time scrubbing
and power washing is happening all over
the city yeah the bottom of my shoes
look clean like it's noticeable how
clear the streets look and how few
homeless encampments there are on major
thoroughfares having been a longtime
resident in the Bay Area you just
naturally start to wonder of like
houseless folks being displaced Public
Works is installing decorative
crosswalks in North Beach and Chinatown
and the Webster Street pedestrian bridge
in Japan toown was recently repainted
the ybab bua Gardens at the Moscone
Center are decked out with new colorful
landscaping and murals paid for by the
clean California Grant just in time for
the 20,000 high-profile CEOs and heads
of state coming into town next week some
people say this should be how it's
always done what about the people who
are here year round you know in like
local hardworking working class barria
folks that's a good question from that
guy why exactly doesn't the city of San
Francisco do this all the time if they
can do it at all then it seems like well
they can do it so why wouldn't they just
do it all the time later in that news
report the new station makes it clear
that the city uh isn't spending any
extra money on this cleanup supposedly
all the funds are coming out of existing
budgets so again they could easily be
doing this all the time so why aren't
they yet again we're facing the threat
of a government shut down later this
month and the administration will
ultimately deal with it the same way
they always do with more spending more
spending will inevitably devalue the
dollar protect your savings by
diversifying into gold with the help of
Birch gold group and here's the best
part when you open Ira with Birch gold
for every $10,000 you spend by December
22nd Birch gold will send you a free
gold bar just text Walsh to 9898917350
and you still get the free gold bars too
with an A+ rating with a Better Business
Bureau thousands of satisfied customers
you can count on Burch gold to help you
transition an existing Ira of 401k into
an IRA in Gold don't let your savings
fall victim to the further devaluation
of the dollar text Walsh to
9898 another local resident in the Som
neighborhood had the same question he
told the New York post quote they've
cleared out the tents on Howard Street
which uh tells me the city had the
capability to do this all along instead
they just do the bare
minimum Mark benof the founder of
Salesforce echoed that sentiment quote
San Francisco has been incredibly clean
beautiful and safe for the last three
days and it's great that the city is
able to put its best foot forward for
this major event that brings in 40,000
people from around the world and $80
million to the economy it is important
to ask why the city cannot be this clean
and safe every single day benof has an
especially uh a good reason to ask that
question since he poured roughly $8
million into prop C in California which
taxed individuals and businesses to
promote homelessness services including
a lot of nonprofits what did he get in
return for that money apparently not
much and that's not surprising when you
hand left-wing nonprofits money to fix
any issue whether it's homelessness or
something more important like
microaggressions in the workplace or
whatever you don't actually give them
incentives to fix the problem instead
you give them incentives to prolong the
problem so they can bu more money from
billionaires so what's the solution then
well it turns out that it's pretty
simple instead of dumping money into
homelessness services and nonprofits all
that was needed this whole time was a
little bit of willpower San Francisco
Chronicle obtained emails from City
officials that demonstrate how easy this
has been to accomplish all along
Christopher McDaniels the city's
superintendent of Street Environmental
Services wrote an email back in
September explaining that um every
street needs to be completely cleared
for the event he wrote quote with APEC
coming I'm concerned about historical
encampments that are close to Priority
areas Daniel's boss added quote we need
to stay on top of the growing
encampments do we have a plan within
days according to the post quote certain
areas including the notorious
intersections of vaness Avenue and
California Street Hyde and Eddie Street
Taylor and Ellis streets were cleared of
homeless
tents now reading all this it's hard not
to laugh a little bit when you think
about the fact that San Francisco's
bureaucrats managed to make the city
look presentable for the leader of
communist China you know it's kind of
like if your wife is a slob most of the
time but then makes a point of like
doing her hair and putting on makeup
whenever the pool boy comes to clean the
pool kind of shows you where her
affections lie might want to be a little
concerned about that and San Francisco
has revealed itself in the same way it
also kind of makes you wonder how San
Francisco might look if xiin ping ran it
instead of just visiting it does anyone
seriously doubt that it would look a lot
better than it does under London breed
and Gavin
Nome but the most important point is
that this proves okay this is a
microcosm that proves what I've been
saying for a long time which is that
these are simple problems to fix and the
government can easily fix them
homelessness crime all the stuff that
makes our cities into unlivable
wastelands it can be you can solve these
problems and in this case it took just a
couple of emails from some mid-level
bureaucrats and it got
done now of course these bureaucrats
have not solved chronic homelessness
quote unquote they've not prevented
people from losing their homes or doing
drugs or developing Mental Illness but
they have moved these people out of
sight and they've used Force to do it
they have cleaned up the city at least
parts of it which means that it can be
done for now at least San Francisco is
doing what is
necessary and this is a very good
indication that as it turns out our
cities again do not have to be
crime-infested cesspools they do not
have to be third world wastelands with
zombified drug addicts walking around
and taking dumps in the street if San
Francisco can make at least parts of
itself look clean and livable in order
to impress China it can make the whole
of itself clean and live livable for the
sake of its citizens if it cared to
but the vast majority of the time San
Francisco doesn't care to do that our
Elites who run the entire country don't
care to do that for the sake of their
own citizens that is the common thread
here you know the left likes to say one
of their favorite little mantras is that
poverty is a policy Choice which
obviously isn't true that's completely
stupid poverty is a fact of life it's an
inevitability in human civilization
social Decay on the other hand is a
choice and if you live in a city where
there are uh again zombie drug addicts
wandering around looking like The
Walking Dead and it's making the city
unlivable that is a policy choice that
does not have to happen it only happens
if it's allowed to happen or perhaps in
our case made to
happen who would have thought that you
know after years of giving drug addicts
taxpayer funded needles and devaluing
the currency and Outsourcing men
manufacturing to China we'd end up with
even more homeless people who would have
thought that suspending the enforcement
of pretty much every misdemeanor would
lead to more misdemeanors like public
urination and public drug use and and
and uh and and worse crimes than that
public robberies public sex
acts now for more than a decade
Democrats solutions to this rapidly
growing crisis has been to throw more
money at the problem and give themselves
more power in the process certainly this
approach has worked out well for Gavin
Nome but it hasn't worked out for the
people living in San
Francisco it tells you a lot that the
city's leaders like so many political
figures all over the country felt no
incentive at any point to make their own
Community better and more prosperous and
more beautiful just for the sake of
their own people they don't care about
their own people the welfare of their
own people simply doesn't motivate them
but when xiin ping and an army of CEOs
are in town then our leaders will spring
into action now those are some people
that politicians really want to
impress what's happening in San
Francisco right now is the end of
plausible deniability for all of these
bureaucrats and elected officials it's
now Beyond any doubt that they are the
reason for the managed decline we are
witnessing in major cities all over the
country this managed decline is
deliberate but by the same token it's
reversible and it can be reversed very
quickly El Salvador fixed its violent
crime problem in a few weeks weeks now
we learn that San Francisco has always
had the ability to end its homelessness
epidemic in a matter of
days and when apek is over and the
floodgates reopen in Soma and the
homeless druggies pour back in that will
be obvious to
everyone maybe even the people who have
the misfortune of living in San
Francisco as oblivious as they all tend
to be hey YouTube thanks for listening
to the show if you'd like access to my
full show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there